a quiet North Oxford Street turned
outdoor party venue one of thousands
held across the country to celebrate the
coronation big lunch and among the
guests two neighbors who'd both been at
Queen Elizabeth's coronation in 1953. oh
it was wonderful but
it was wonderful as it was for the
people yesterday I really do I was being
very naughty because I didn't really
like the boyfriend who was taking me but
he got me to take
so I suddenly found I was 18
. an aptly named pop-up Pub kept the
drinks flowing while lunch came from
neighboring kitchens up and down the
street quite a royal spread for a street
bone locally to be somewhat Republican
in its sympathies I
that's true to say that there are
several Republicans
um
are some mixed feelings about the Royal
toast but um we you know we wish we wish
Charles well and it's a good opportunity
to celebrate for all of us the residents
of this street say they've been doing a
Summer Street party every year for
nearly 30 years and that this one is as
much about their Community as it is
about monarchy but the message from the
royal family is that this Sunday is an
opportunity for communities around the
country to forge closer ties the king's
younger sister Princess Anne was at one
event in Swindon to cement that message
while outside his official residence in
Downing Street prime minister Rishi
sumac hosted lunch for Community Heroes
and Ukrainian refugees
[Music]
back in Oxford another lunch event was
held to bring different faiths together
Sudanese Sufi Muslims joined Sunni and
sheer clerics along with representatives
from the Jewish Christian Hindu Sikh and
Buddhist communities in that it
reflected a major part of the coronation
service when representatives from a
number of faiths handed the king objects
of his coronation regalia we want a
peaceful world we need to be inclusive
and be living as a one single family and
that's what the King has stood for for
many decades and says brought that to
fruition and it was wonderful
and while coronation key should be in
the officially recognized big lunch
recipe here on the lawn on a sun dappled
Sunday the coronation Biryani was going
down a treat Harry Fawcett Al Jazeera
Oxford